LIKE THE BRUTAL 2-WEEK SELLOFF
IN FEBRUARY.
BUCKLE YOUR SEAT BELTS FOR NEXT
WEEK.
>> Bret: CHINA IS FIGHTING BACK
AGAINST PRESIDENT TRUMP IMPOSING
MASSIVE TARRIFS ON THEIR
PRODUCTS SENT TO THE U.S.
THAT LEAVES THE WORLD'S 2
LARGEST ECONOMIES ON THE BRINK
OF AN ECONOMIC CONFLICT.
JILLIAN LOOKS AT THIS.
>> FARMERS ARE FEARFUL THAT A
TRADE WAR WITH CHINA IS ON THE
HORIZON.
>> I AM TRYING TO MAKE SURE WE
GET IT THROUGH TO THE
ADMINISTRATION.
I THINK THEY UNDERSTAND IT, BUT
I WANT TO MAKE SURE THAT THEY
UNDERSTAND HOW IT AFFECTS THE
PEOPLE IN THE MIDWEST AND MY
BOTTOM LINE.
>> CHINA IS THREATENING TO
IMPOSE TARRIFS ON UP TO $3
BILLION WORTH OF U.S. IMPORTIS.
AMERICAN FARMERS CAUTION THAT
SUCH A MOVE MIGHT CAUSE
COMPETITORS TO STEP IN AND GRAB
THEIR BUSINESS.
>> BRAZIL AND ARGENTINA ARE
WILLING AND EGOR TO TAKE OUR
SHARE OF THE CHINESE MARKET.
>> CHINA IS CONSIDERING A 15%
TARIFF ON AMERICAN EXPORTIS.
PLUS 25% ON PORK AND ALUMINUM.
CHINA DRAFTED A LIST OF 128
AMERICAN PRODUCTS TELL TARGET IN
THE FUTURE SHOULD THE U.S. AND
CHINA FAIL TO REACH A TRADE
AGREEMENT.
>> WE COULD LOOSE 504-BILLION
DOLLARS WITH CHINA.
IT'S BAD.
>> IN ADDITION TO THE DISPUTES
OVER HARD GOODS, THE 2 SIDES ARE
CLASHING OVER THE TECH SECTOR.
ALARMING SIGNS OF A MAJOR
FALLOUT EMERGED.
THE ADMINISTRATION BLOCKED CHINE
FROM BUYING QUALCOMM AND CHINA
PULLED ITS INVESTMENT FROM U.S.
POWERHOUSE BLACKSTONE.
>> OUR SOCIETY DEPEND ON
INNOVATION.
THE CHINESE ARE TAKING THE
FRUITS OF THAT INNOVATION AND
STEALING IT IN WAYS WHICH ARE
PREDATORY AND UNACCEPTABLE.
>> THIS ON-GOING TRADE DISPUTE.